[Music]
Christmas Eve has turned into a
nightmare for a group of people being
held hostage in the Liquor Mart behind
me here's what we know for certain sent
a Santos is the owner sent a slicker
mark
Merry Christmas very yes very kate
daniels is working the counter today
your link to old men in my child hostage
right now Karl's patrol vehicles down
the road and it appears to have been in
some kind of altercation we may or may
not be the hostage-taker
start an act like a damn police officer
thank you sir what are you doing here
anyway my father used to live here so I
came here to turnfight now
it was partner arrested me for no reason
true he had paraphernalia Drano the weed
was his oh [ __ ] it's such a dumb shits
out there
the suspect was police for Christmas get
out of here
we want to get everyone out of here
safely and reunited with their loved
ones well you do we're gonna get it Time
Machine Billy
[Music]
no no and no no [ __ ] off you got
yourself in a real mess here we can't
negotiate with a crazy person it's not a
damn movie Billy you're not Samuel
[ __ ] Jackson
[Music]